it's the answer
I think if you stop me you did dimitra's
it works I'm not getting it okay if you
refuse to identify yourself in charge
what's the charge
what's the charge mr. Jarvis what's your
charge I just told you my name it's
about a car
what's the talk about for what you're
pulling him over for something you need
his identification you don't need one I
know my rights
and I don't have to give to you just one
plate like so now I'm not playing a game
it's my rights so I'm not giving it to
you I'm not violating my rights to plead
you and you see police officers are
harassing me and they won't tell me why
b-team but I won't let me go my brother
actually attended
this man state purple just why we
well-rounded
you put both fencer side by side you can
and I and like as soon as I've seen the
video with Sam I recognize this voice
immediately nobody gave us their name or
advance number they were Houston I would
like you know we could could have got
that information like that night if it
would have been some disciplinary action
to where it didn't get to that point
with him
you